à une semaine des championnats de france
tous vont savoir technique nous mettons
au service de l'art fait c'est clair
pour tout le monde
ultime entraînement et dernier conseil
pour ses élèves du pôle espoirs de surf
et les vagues at heart and sons ce jour
là au rendez vous l'occasion pour ces
sept jeunes sélectionnés aux
championnats de france de peaufiner leur
technique
quand tu vas sortir ta première
manoeuvre
équilibre vitesse et enchaîne
directement en appréhendant on est on
est content de partir parce que c'est
bien de voir vers d'autres endroits
ça fait un petter solberg en martinique
c'est vraiment c'est vraiment
une compétition que l'on attend toute
l'année c'est surtout quand je vais
mettre tous les cra pour aller dans
l'eau que je vais vraiment commencé à
stresser mais je m'entraîne bien j'ai
des bonnes bonnes vagues des bonnes
sessions
donc pour moi ça va depuis un an
ces jeunes sportifs ont intégré le pôle
espoir de surf de martinique pour ces
championnats de france
l'accent est mis sur la préparation
physique et sur la stratégie ram et le
mieux possible jusqu'au pic sélectionner
les vagues qui rapporteront le plus de
points et y réaliser les figures les
plus radicales ont fait des
entraînements physiques mais pour sa
part meilleur - s'essouffler dans l'eau
et tout et on travaille beaucoup au
lycée répond pétition pour pour se
mettre en jambes les entraînements
techniques sont au top on a des super
bon coach et les entraînements physiques
last depuis cette année on fait de
l'argot m et ça nous aide vraiment pour
la puissance donc c'est super c'est
arrivé aujourd'hui techniquement à
mettre tous leurs progrès technique au
service de la compétition donc ça veut
dire que ce sont des gamins qui
aujourd'hui sont efficaces dans leur
série ils vont pouvoir vraiment mettre
le meilleur d'eux-mêmes et montrer le
meilleur d'eux mêmes dans le cadre de
leur série ces sept jeunes font partie
des 15 martinique est sélectionné pour
le championnat de france de surf à
hossegor
ils tenteront tous de ramener le titre
de champion de france à l'issue de la
compétition le 27 octobre prochain